how did you get the deal because now
grab probably has their choice like
you're saying
so you know take us into you know what
none of us have access to is
how does that board decide to go with
brad as opposed to goldman
they hire uh uh advisors to advise them
like an allen and company like a bank
yeah and ultimately
um it takes courage on the part of a
board because if you think about what a
board
uh you know you know the old saying you
don't get fired hiring mckenzie
right you don't get fired hiring goldman
sachs you don't get fired hiring morgan
stanley let me be very clear
goldman and morgan stanley are great
partners of us they're extremely smart
they're extremely capable and they will
have important roles to play in the
process
it doesn't mean that their role should
not evolve
we're going to re-architect this in a
way my north star
is very clear what is in the best
interest of founders companies and
employees
of the ecosystem that has been so good
to me i mean that's where it should
start right those are the people who got
the product
got the opportunity to your desk so why
are we giving all the spoils to some
other group of people
so when when they said to you hey brad
why should we go with you as opposed to
you know one of these banks and you're
talking to the advisors
what was your pitch because i i do know
you you offered some very specific
things
that maybe some other specs have not
offered so you've
and each of these specs correct me if
i'm wrong you as the
promoter which is a weird term but it is
a
sponsor
sponsor okay you as the sponsor sort of
a weird term but
better you as a sponsor you get to
define the terms
um so it's not a standard term so what
were the terms you pitched
well first like any great product
like what we've done over the last year
is to
deconstruct the entire value chain of an
ipo
and to say like this isn't about
flipping a spock
this is about building a product like
i've built in four or three other
companies like rich's build it
you know we we took a zillow approach
what is the
i buy of the ipo how can you deconstruct
that so part of it right chris conforty
joined our team chris built over 100 ipo
books
for goldman sachs right so the guts of
an ipo
is right to ser bring together two sides
of the marketplace
the company and the world's best public
market investors
so knowing those public market investors
you know will dan off and sonu at
fidelity
knowing tony kim at blackrock knowing
you know just go through the list
those are your buyers so having trust
and relationships and altimeter has 15
years
of trust in relationships with these
portfolio managers
because we sit on the same side we
compare notes with them about
public companies that we're looking at
chris conforti
has a decade of experience with them
building books
at goldman sachs so we know how to build
a better book how to price how to
allocate how to do those things
and so from our perspective right that
is the guts but now you can expand the
aperture jason right on the capital
markets team so i brought
you know we brought derek wong for
example on board derek was the head of
ir and pr for tableau
right so helping these companies
understand how to tell the narrative how
to present the narrative
right but the important thing is this
like why
number one what is the objective of most
companies give me the best possible
public market investors
at the fairest price with the least
amount of distraction
and that's what we delivered we
delivered a better cap table
at a fairer price with a hell of a lot
less distraction than they would have
gotten in a typical
experience so we're i think a great
partner too i noticed two points
um you locked up your shares for three
years
so our sponsor promote um is locked up
for three years i'm never going to bring
a company public
that i'm not willing to lock up my
sponsor promote in because frankly i
want to bring
the best of the best right i'm not
trying there are a lot of places that
spax
will offer great alternatives to
companies
right like for example you think of you
know lucid you know which is
an interesting company that went public
by way of spack with michael klein
right or you think of you know these
vertical takeoff companies you know reid
hoffman's doing
just incredible stuff joby yeah with
really interesting companies companies
that i would love to see exist but
that's not what altimeter does
so the really fanciful moon shots
no right and they'll be and guess what
chamath is better at that
reid is better at that so they will own
that category in the capital markets
right what we're very focused on is what
we've done
for i've done for 20 years which is
focus on the world's best
internet and software companies gaming
and fintech
right and for a select few every year
we're going to help them go full stack
on the altimeter platform but we'll
participate
in 40 other ipos where we'll be an
expert advisor on their traditional bank
ipo like we did with snowflake where we
helped
anchor that or like roblox where we
helped cornerstone the direct list and
worked close with dave and
and mike as they brought that company
public by way of direct list
we do not we're not a spack hammer only
trying to pound a spec nail we are
what do you think of this what i'll call
questionable inventory
that are going out by a spax you know
for every
you know company that seems really
legitimate you're going to have a fiskar
you're going to have uh a nicola i i'm
me i'm saying these names i'm not going
to put it to you to say these names but
i think those two are
you know either frauds or destined to be
zeros or just disastrous investments
that's my personal belief
um but you are doing a spec chamois
doing specs and so people put these all
in one bucket
totally how do you think about the low
quality
you can pick which ones you think are
low quality i just gave two names that i
think are extremely low quality
that i think wouldn't go from you could
take a zero off their valuations and i
wouldn't buy them at 500 million
the first thing alone five billion the
first thing i would say
is and i heard you said on cnbc earlier
today right
that stocks are not lottery tickets i've
said this on cnbc have tweeted about it
there's not enough diligence going on
by way of investors they think this is
all get rich quick schemes
spax are dangerous i said on cnbc a few
weeks ago i got a lot of grief for it
that we're short
a lot of specs and a lot of dspacs
because we run a hedge fund
because you have misalignment you have
average companies at best that are
overpriced this is
buyer beware right buyer beware
and and i am 100 in your camp on
you know we need to have full and fair
disclosure right we need to have
enforcement
i started you know back in 1997 98
literally
in fact i was i was the regulator of the
indiana securities division
i ran the indiana secretary of state's
office and
some of the stuff i see going on uh you
know
promoting et cetera i just think is is
is on the line or crossing the line
so altimeter is exclusively focused on
taking the best public
best companies in the world public and
and and partnering them with the world's
best
institutional investors right right
institutional investors
and giving a more curated
ipo to the best companies i think about
like [ __ ] twilio octa companies that
were in our private portfolio
right that i wanted to own more of as
they went public
i wanted to be a great partner as they
went public but
now we can now we can to those types of
companies that are in our portfolio or
our friends portfolios